for it I'm waiting for the intro music
this is the intro music this is what you
get it's just silence yeah you're
welcome
I wrote it myself just like my act and
it's the same silence so it's great it's
going Islands guys what's up it's Dave
fails we're streaming live today this is
so exciting I never stream live but I
look what are we like whatever we're on
all the cameras we're on both cameras
we're only on one camera listen I don't
I don't know I'm not under the table at
our crotches that's just at my house in
my living room the coffee table there's
also a dick on my carpet wait this is
actually real I feel like that's not
surprising to me like I feel like you
would have dicks you like just kind of
dicks by the way guys I'd be like art
art dicks there it's art dick oh yeah
like art deco bollocks you would just
have like a beautiful statue of one
thank you you know for a for yay well I
have a lot of fake ones to accommodate
for how few real ones can I just tell
you first of all let me introduce my
very good friend who is absolutely
hilarious comedian Viner snapchatter
fine - maybe the only person who shows
her ass on social media more than I do
so you should definitely follow cheating
on me right now you want to see butt
cheeks and funny jokes this is your
[ __ ] I mean right yo I'm your girl I
think that you should do what I did I
wrote [ __ ] Trump on my butt cheeks and I
tweeted it and yeah I think we should
start a movement of just people writing
[ __ ] cha cha but on there but it's
classy and that's why I did it is it
classy no what are your parents think of
when you show your butt my mom what do
you get from them first of all it's
creepy as [ __ ] because my dad leaves
comments on things no yes but what my
dad does is he comments back I told my
dad he's never allowed to like say who
he is and he's not allowed to add people
because I don't want him instigating but
he does leave comments on my social
media about other people's comments like
when someone leaves something rude that
pisses him off oh he like he's like
protecting you it's like defensive but
my dad
but he's like a total stoner and he's
drunk most of the time and it's just
creepy honest oh he sounds like every
guy I date you and me single oh god no
no first of all he's not saying you set
me up with your dad absolutely not he
has the cutest beer gut
he's like tall and thin with like huge
guy his dad belly yes total dad his
alcoholic belly yeah oh it's like hard
the stomach's like it is yeah it's like
a fetus inside yeah a beer my dad really
my dad like he was like all in shape and
then and then that hard belly and then
he had the bureau fetus yeah so the dick
thing check this out yes a dick on your
nightstand Wow I have to I have one on
the coffee table that's like a
conversation piece actually but the
reason I have it is because I host this
show on the Playboy channel right and we
do weird we explore weird sex things and
one of the things we did this season is
we went to Allentown Pennsylvania and I
got to go to a build-your-own dildo
workshop what I swear to god you mold
sounds amazing it was I put my name on
the side of the penis just like I do
with real you know dicks that I'm on you
you can but I haven't cuz I just feel
like it's not it doesn't feel like the
same quality as like the ones you buy
yeah I mean at the store so I don't want
to mess it up but it has my name on it
and it's pretty cute it's very girthy
it's wide but I keep it on the coffee
table what color isn't I made it like
okay it turned out pepto-bismol pink it
was supposed to be like fuchsia it's
like the color of a real of a real like
Irish dick
I don't think dicks are pink I've never
seen a pink dick yeah
you know I have it I've only I can still
count the number of guys I've slept with
it's under 20 yeah same
lily under 20 that makes me feel so good
yeah well okay so what's going on with
you are you single right now single I'm
so sad that your roommate didn't come
because Josh yeah okay I'm I he [ __ ]
blocks me also I [ __ ] block myself
does he really [ __ ] block you
we need to explain the roommate dynamic
that you have a Josh cuz oh it's so
weird she lives with a comedian his name
is Josh Nasar he's funny he's crazy as
[ __ ] baby the most person I've ever met
crazy he's cute though like he is cute
like if I met him at a bar I'd give him
a shot I love the story between you and
Josh when you first met because he
followed you he did he followed me to
saddle ranch so that he but you guys
still argue about you inviting him I did
not hate him and him asking another
comic she was over comics so I just
think that's funny that that's still a
debate of how you guys first met
actually I brought I came to the comedy
store with a couple friends and I was
performing and back then I was like
literally performing and like hot
outfits like I think I had on like
cutoff like cutoff shorts like I have on
net wearing right now I looked I looked
way more like I did my hair bad as old
she's not wearing a top she's like I was
just I was casual back I was like people
don't strip in the belly room I thought
you had to show your belly in the belly
room but so Josh I walked up and of
course immediately Josh goes are you
comedian and I was like yeah and here's
like oh my god how do I not know you we
have to date it was literally like that
fast yeah and then I was like oh well
you know I'm here with some friends we
started talking and then I told him we
were going over to saddle ranch and then
he showed up and then he showed up at
saddle ranch she's like I remember him
talking about you and he's like she's so
hot like every female comic wouldn't you
say josh is like tries with every Josh
once a comedian girlfriend that's why I
thought you guys would end up together I
don't think he wants a comedian
girlfriend who don't because when he
asked me are you a comic I expected cuz
I asked guys this like I met oh my god
Dana you have to see this guy I met the
hottest guy at The Comedy Store the
other night and I was like please for
the love of Jesus tell me you're not a
cop don't be a comic don't be a comic
he's been doing stand-up for a month so
I think yeah I think he's still [ __ ]
he's not really a comic yeah
like that I'm such an [ __ ] but like
when someone's like like they just
started comedy like like a hot dude
I'm just immediately like cuz I know I
wasn't funny when I was a month and you
know it is I'm just like I know I'm sure
it's such a bummer though you can't
because when you meet them and they're
just starting out there's this
awkwardness of like if you do date them
half the conversation is like so how how
do you get on these shows how did you
get on these so how did yeah you're
right we can't he's so hot though and so
when I asked him if he was a comic and
he said yes I was disappointed whereas
that's what I thought was gonna happen
when Josh asked me if I was a comic I
thought he was gonna be like Oh bummer
but yeah I was like great yeah but so
you guys live together we live together
I'm actually getting my own place you
are first
you're moving out of this anybody wants
anybody out there I'm here
so I'm eight I'll move in with literally
anyone but for the longest time I was
convinced you guys were together
everybody is but you're never you guys
have never hooked up no even made out no
you guys cuddle we did but it was it was
like a it wasn't like a sexual cuddle it
was just like a platonic friend cuddle
and yeah I got really lying down and
then he gets kind of like lovey and then
but it's just interesting because I feel
like our friendship has blocked me off
romantically how so does he really [ __ ]
like you I think it's just like I get
this validation from a guy in a way that
I'm not seeking it like like emotionally
and mentally like he's like a boyfriend
to me he's real a husband / brother he's
more like a husband cuz you guys don't
[ __ ] he's out yeah it has bagley
although you do cuddles and then that's
that takes away no you know what it is
really gozman because we share a living
space yeah and you guys create stuff
together you did a podcast together
you're very funny together you bind
together all the time yeah we make we
make ridiculous videos would you like
man-on-the-street stuff yes you have
like a dream relationship just without
the sex that's sex yeah but also it's
like
I just think I would need somebody to
date that isn't so like like up and down
and so like you know Annie's a little
bipolar II yeah but in a great way Josh
hilarious yeah but let me ask you this
like I just get message from Josh right
now like stop no Josh was supposed to be
on today but he's having like an
emergency medical procedure so Josh we
love you and I hope your father talks
that's what I call it - I call it an
emergency emergency Botox but let me ask
you this I was out the other night okay
I went to a club I went to a [ __ ]
declare I went to one oh can you picture
me at a like first of all this is like
me trying to look sexy is where I've
shorts and a tank top
sexy well thanks but you can't wear this
so I can La Crosse wait wear that well
no so I'm going to 1 oak I go home and
put on like a hot dress yeah then I get
there and I realize that in LA girls go
to the club boom whatever the [ __ ] there
were girls dressed like this I'd gone to
the club like this if I put on just like
some dope accessories everyone's wearing
like overalls for real
but yeah so check this out so I hit up
this guy who I've flirted with a little
bit but we've never hooked up and he
used to be a manager there so he's like
very hooked up there so I was like oh
he'll be a fun person to club with cuz
yeah it'll you know everything will be
taken care of with he's the manager of
the club he used to be he manages a
different club now but he used to manage
that so did you get battles oh well
that's the thing we did so I go there we
had the best time give Authority we went
to after party then after the
after-party he starts trying to hook up
well of course
anyway yeah why didn't I this is the
thing he's very very close friends with
one of my very best guy friends
Jackson McQueen who's this black dude
who's super hot hot for her as [ __ ] who
I play tennis with all the time and he
has hot friends yeah and Jax and I are
really good friends we've never had out
of it I know but what happened is in the
moment I suddenly was like I can't hook
up with you because you're such good
friends with Jackson it stopped me from
doing it and it made me totally have a
moment
I was like why will I not hook up with
one of Jackson's friends
it made me in my head be like don't you
like I don't know I don't know Jackson
if you're watching she offer like no I
even text Jackson the next day and I go
hey I'm your boy tried to hook up with
me last night and I couldn't do it
because you guys are such good friend
what did he say he said well you're
grown up you can hook up with whoever
you want and I was like I know but I
felt weird about it and I swear to God I
don't think like it made me reassess my
whole relationship with him I was like
does that mean I have feelings for him
does that I just in my mind I'm like
what if one day down the road I fall in
love with Jackson and then he doesn't
want to date me because I I banged his
friend I think that the best
relationships start with friendships
right like you and Josh that's the
question the last guy that I dated no
for real the last guy that I dated um
that I was with but not I didn't have
the title we were friends first yeah and
um oh I just found out today by the way
that he is moving to San Francisco to be
with his girlfriend now okay two months
ago when things ended we work together
just two months ago two months ago we
were together and I was like we were
exclusive
not seeing anybody else together and
then he sort of traveling a lot for work
and I got insecure obviously and I was
like I just like I would know I want to
be with you I don't want to be with
anybody else so can we be in a
relationship and he's like I'm not ready
for that
wait so you are exclusively dating you
knew for sure yes how did you know if
you'd never had that talk we did have
that talk that we were exclusive oh but
we didn't have a title see can I tell
you something the last guy I was like
dating dating like kind of seriously
dating we didn't have a title on it
either but we were hanging out like two
two nights a week we were texting or
talking every day I mean I'd like the
week is a lot fro it right and he might
have been sleeping with other people but
like you know if he
it couldn't have been that often cuz we
were like so in contact like I knew when
he was at work I knew so I was like
alright I'm just gonna bring it up cuz I
wasn't really seeing other people
anymore and how long was this going on
for we had been dating like that for
like three or four months when I brought
it up okay oh that's oh that's a long
time it's a while right well I was
waiting because you know what I never
mind was like not even two though really
I never bring it up because I know the
label [ __ ] things but in this one
scenario I felt like I had to bring it
up because some of his friends were
starting to hit on me and some of my
friends were hitting on him and it just
got to the point where no one knew we
were really dating and I was like can we
just be a thing and then when I said
that when I tell you he pulled over like
a [ __ ] ghost like God like he'll
still hit me up to hook up so he's
emotionally unavailable I'm really
attracted to emotionally unavailable
because your emotion in available I know
it's great I'm the say I'm struggle I'm
literally struggling with the same thing
I think years now I think there's
something about our generation like do
you know that you get scared I'm scared
of rejection and I'm scared of
abandonment and so I push away anyone
that's like obviously super into me and
wants to be with me I push them away
mm-hmm and then the people that aren't
you try to run after nice yeah chase so
but you know what my new thing is I
started doing you should do this loving
yourself
oh well unless you count masturbating
I'm not very good at that masturbating
okay then yes I did that today for I
actually think I have a problem I
masturbate for so long you know I go
there yeah I go through like periods of
watching a lot of porn mm-hmm and I'll
do it like the whole day and then I'll
feel really ashamed really and then I'll
have to tell somebody and enough to tell
bit people what I watch because I get
him I get so ashamed that I feel like
telling somebody makes it okay I texted
Nicole Aimee Schreiber
I texted Nicole today and I go dude I've
been masturbating for two hours smells
like me you know I think she does
five minutes later she posted a photo of
her vibrator on Instagram she has a box
of vibrators so do i and no but they're
all like expensive like she like invests
very no I think she's just like this
well she also admitted on here that she
hasn't had sex in a year I mean you got
to have a few vibrators if you're not
having wait why a year no what's the
longest you've ever gone no more than a
year you've gone a year that I've gone
here I was pretty screwed up after my my
first big break up five years and I
didn't sleep with anybody here when was
that that was like six years ago
oh wow so have you been in a serious
relationship since that no me neither
serious relationship I think that and I
hear it's cuz you're in LA I find one
almost impossible and I keep going back
to ask do you go back to guys that you
shouldn't be with I kind of I don't know
like you know what I I reach out that's
what put the vibe zone you send a text
then attack is it lemon they write who
it is at least I didn't block you you
know I've started happy you know that's
the world I block guys I blocked their
number to keep me from texting that I
okay i'll race their number in my phone
yeah if they really hurt me and then
i'll block them on everything me too and
then I'll go back and unblock and lo I
blocked them on everything and then I go
god damn it why did I block them now
they don't see like how great I'm doing
and they don't like see my photo and get
like jealous like after I block them I
always regret blocking them yeah but the
thing is for me I have to block guys I
have to block guys that I'm dating also
because what happens is I start to
consider them in like my tweets and my
Instagram yeah
do that like something will happen the
night and when you're with them and you
think of a funny joke and you're like
yeah this is great
yeah or I'll just like I'll be talking
to someone else and something funny will
happen and I'll want to like tweet that
text but then I'll be like oh these
other this other guy I'm dating is gonna
see that text and he's gonna know I'm
talking to some other thing and it's
gonna cause problems yeah most normal
people don't tweet like they're funny
flirty conversations they're having yeah
but we do yeah well well oh I wanted to
finish telling you about this last dude
please so this is something I just
turned out today so that's why when I
came in I was kind of like I was like
kind of down I'm no I'm fine I need
drugs just like adderall yes
we'll make me skinny it will yes
definitely so he um couldn't have the
title right yeah it was the thing cuz I
was just engaged I guess like whatever
like he was engaged like six months ago
it was he was still getting over that
and he couldn't do the whole like title
thing or whatever which is fine but I
was like I don't want to continue like
putting like time and effort into effort
yeah my feelings keep growing for you
like every time we hang out more core my
emotions are getting like run and I like
I want I don't wanna you know see where
this is going and see maybe down the
road if you're ready and then like kind
of not be like that would really suck so
I was like and so you couldn't do that
so then I ended it so I mean whatever
maybe I broke broke it off but like now
he's in a relationship and he's moving
to a different city to be with her in
hit and we have a mutual friend and he
I'm gonna probably a friend and she has
a party a birthday party and I'm pretty
sure he's gonna be there and I'm like I
schedule like don't go it's early don't
put yourself in that is very good well
then you know what you need to do you
need to go with like the hottest guy
ever
we're drew Barrymore right you need to
start Monaco is like a legit like a
famous actor or an NFL football player
or someone that's gonna make this
be like oh [ __ ] like you need to take
someone in his head
apparently I broke up I broke it up with
him I broke broke it up well if you baby
made him like can we be together or not
and he was like not then you kind of
ended it but I mean you did you know
what makes me feel I'm just like I have
issues no you don't when guys say that
they're not ready for a relationship it
means they don't want one with you
because any guy that meets the girl that
yeah crazy about this
yes yeah this made me realize that but I
was like so you you don't want to really
[ __ ] with me but I because I wasn't
right for you right and that's fine but
don't give me this [ __ ] run around
all the truth I say all those rude on
this show do all the [ __ ] truth
that's it's so much better for like when
guys hit me up that I'm not interested
in it's mean but at this point I just go
you know what like I went on a date with
a guy recently i literally text the next
day when he was like hey let's hang
again and I go you know what I had a
really great time with you but I just
didn't feel like any chemistry or
romantic connection so I'm gonna save
you the trouble of taking me out again I
think that's so much better that is then
like stringing someone on I used to this
is so bad this is before I had
boundaries and I still don't have
boundaries but I would go on a date and
it would be terrible right and then I
would text the guy had so much fun can't
wait to see you again
didn't have fun don't want to see him
again
but I felt bad it's like the Seinfeld
episode well is it George or Jerry who
can't stop one of them can't stop like
every time he's like great we should do
this again sometime
I would do that with guys and then I
would end up having to go out with him
again knowing that I didn't want to go
out with them again I just like fell see
I'm good at not doing that cuz I just
get tired of going out with guys I'm not
into yeah so now I just I don't but like
there's a guy that literally I finally
had to end it because the guy that
didn't want the so the guy you did the
right thing you ended it with the guy
that wouldn't give you what you wanted
and I further
I've never done that with a guy but
that's right yeah and it honestly hurt
for like a week
yeah and I've never been in a better
place I'm telling you Kate like I've
grown so much from that experience like
that I feel like I feel like this had to
happen see and that's the thing that's
where I'm trying to get to because what
I do is I try to end it and then when
they're like I can't give you that but I
can give you this I settle for Less
because I want to keep them like I want
to keep a piece of them you just don't
want to be you have a hard time being no
I don't mind being alone but if there's
someone that I am really into part of my
brain is like well maybe sacrificing a
little is better than not having this
person at all but then what ends up
happening is like I even though I say
that I keep trying to get them to really
be with me anyway so in the end I end up
driving them away because you work too
hard yeah but like the problem is guys
will never put closure on a situation
where they can keep getting laid they
won't do it if they know you might keep
talking them even if it's once a month
even if it's six months from now they
won't say I don't want to see you
anymore
they won't do it dudes have no standards
that's true
most guys you said the girls like they
just hook up with like like okay my
roommate I'm not gonna say his name
right but he brings home and he knows
he's not into them he knows that they're
annoying or like okay women if a guy is
annoying and stupid and boring to be
around we're not gonna sleep with you
that's true guys will don't sleep with
the girl that's annoying options we have
you're a hot girl you can [ __ ] anybody
you want why is that gross to me though
I don't know why that's just like see I
I get it because I know guys are trying
so hard to get laid that like I kinda I
don't know babies because my age now and
I'm so horny all the time that there's
part of me it's like I won't lie like I
never used to hook up with randoms ever
ever ever and I will never hook up on
the road no quote random
but definitely now like fun on the road
and I meet a really hot guy and I've
been hooked up in a while I consider it
at least I used to not even consider it
every time I go on the road I meet a guy
like more often than not for real like a
guy that's like so dope like a guy I
would always said a guy I would like for
sure date flash marry maybe like the
coolest guys every guy that I talk to
that I mean I still keep in touch with
her yeah yeah of course
every guy talk to you that I'm like so
into never lives in LA never always
somewhere else and I'm like great this
is never the male comics do and I want
to have a guy in every city so that when
I go there I have a good boyfriend in
town why don't we do that I never do
that and I'm so bored on the road I
could have a good boy if you want to be
my boyfriend in any town you can you're
gonna get like DMS are flooding right
now can I tell you the new thing and I
started doing that I think you should do
because it's really helped my life
kegels I think it's illegal though
kegels yeah that lifting weights with my
vagina no I got an app on my phone okay
I have a bad habit of letting guys be
shitty to me and then I get mad at them
for a while and I don't talk to them for
like a week or two but then eventually I
start being like maybe he wasn't that
bad maybe I overreacted the sex is good
the cuddle was good above all whatever
right and I ended up reaching out so
what I started doing is I downloaded an
app on my phone that records phone calls
what so when I talked to them then we
were right and they're a total dick and
they're like [ __ ] you like a guy the
other day told me hey you need to back
the [ __ ] off if you ever want any shot
with me he said that alone yeah I have
it recorded so I made it the ringtone
for him if he texts me ever again that's
brilliant
but I also don't know what's crazier the
fact that you're recording a phone call
or the fact that you're having a phone
call who talks on the phone well I mean
it's like I know anybody texts I know
but if you're arguing with someone you
talk to them on the phone don't you is
this the guy that you were talking about
like a little month ago I'm not sure
same dude I don't know
your dick strike girl it probably is so
I shouldn't have been dating the when it
taxed oh you hear him you know if he tax
it'll say you need to back the [ __ ] off
you're just like you look like a crazy
person if he's just like texting you
non-stop honestly I mean because now
anytime that I'm like oh maybe he was
sweet I can listen to that and be like
nope yeah next yeah yeah you should get
the app the only problem is it records
every phone call every single one so now
I have like every phone call recorded to
have to go through and delete them all
the time to take a lot of memory up
right yeah that's hilarious
how sad is my life I feel like every
time I talk to you you're like I have
this app for you last one some dating
redo dating a Brea they did not accept
me [ __ ] it the app suck I'm not famous
enough to be on my ass yeah you it sucks
anyway everyone I meet on there's a
skateboarder why dad a guy shove it a
date yeah professional skaters count and
DJ's know yeah all DJs and skateboarders
a tattoo artist I can't with DJ no I
don't want to date a DJ cool you can
press a button wait sign your computer
DJ's are legit like I'd recently learned
that some DJ's actually compose their
own music which ones no no I don't
remember someone saw a DJ taught me I
don't buy it I don't know there's a
little high I could be mistaken anyway
so Dana what what dating apps are you
dating so are you dating anyone then are
you taking a break now that that
douchebag guy I took a break from for
like three months
hold on one was March oh my god uh yeah
I've taken her I needed to not date yeah
I needed to focus on myself I did that
cuz I don't I feel like I'm always like
seeking yeah and it's like
I need to just validate myself I'm
always try seeking the outside
validation it's like I'm like playing
this like weird scenario in my past
where I'm like trying to like like every
guy I date is a different version of my
father oh my - like I love alcoholics
have you ever been laying in bed with a
guy I was laying in bed with a guy who
you know who I dated who you thought I
would marry and you know I was he's a
comic and I was laying yes I was laying
in bed with him one time and I literally
looked over and looked at him and
thought to myself oh my god like I had
this moment where I literally was like
this I had a deja vu moment of when I
was a kid laying in bed with my dad like
I was like he is my father he looks like
my father
he smelled like my father everything
about I was like holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
my father yeah I almost threw up I was
like so sick to my stomach I like I like
that though that's what's weird about me
like I was cuddling with the guy and he
I was putting my head on his chest okay
how you still live with my dad and your
daddy and I was like we don't we weren't
having sex maybe it's not maybe it's not
that weird oh but we have hooked up
there was a romantic thing and I was
lying there and I was like this is so
soothing and comforting and I had that
memory and then I was just like oh my
god weird
every guy felt crazy in love with is my
father well there's your dad there's a
book called um women who love too much
that I read and it's literally it says
in this book it's about girls that come
from like broken homes or have like
daddy issues
oh yeah and it says in this boil all all
girl all women yeah it says in this book
if you meet a guy and you're instantly
like insanely attracted to him like you
just have that immediate chemistry that
immediate spark and you want to [ __ ] him
he's probably some version of your and
you should run the book says you should
like if you meet the way you should run
the other way from that person Wow which
is depressing cuz that's exactly what I
look
I want that instant heat it's like fire
right it's like a good chemistry and
you're just like you just get lost in
them and like time disappears it's like
the best feeling but then it's like hot
it's like a drug right right you get
high high low low the lows are low I
have a question I wish someone would
call and answer this so we need a guy
here cuz I want to know when guys cuz
when I have that kind of chemistry with
a guy hmm
that is when I catch feelings very
quickly even if they suck even if
they're dicks I confuse that chemistry
with like I create things we have in
common
I like create scenarios where like we
could date even though we probably
should in every guy I start dating I am
already like envisioning the wedding and
like how he's gonna raise my children
and I don't even know if I want show you
serious I definitely don't want a
wedding I envision our life together and
our future and literally we haven't even
been on one date later I swear to god
wait like every guy every guy that I
that what you just mentioned you know
when you that like spark we know that
means yeah and yeah instantly are like
I'm in do you have you ever seen Kat
Ryan you know Kat Ryan Hart right yeah
have you ever seen her show my super
overactive imagination it's like a web
show but it's really funny you ever seen
it no it's literally about this every
episode she goes on a date with a guy
and it basically goes into a dream
sequence of her imagining what her whole
life would be like if she was with this
guy yeah but then it cuts back to the
reality of the day and it's usually
awful it's usually like you know the guy
hates her or she gets waste and does
something embarrassing it's always like
she ruins it but it's really fun in real
life though I mean like that's that's
like like I make it way more better in
my head than it actually is I mean but
my question is do you think when the guy
has that chemistry with you like do you
think when the sex is Aaron you're here
can I ask you a question
Aaron's my producer he you're gonna have
to answer a question but as a guy if you
have that crazy chemistry with a girl
the first time you hook up like do you
catch feelings the way women do yeah
really sure is that normal you think for
most guys probably not it's
because your your sensitive soul are you
down to have problem yeah I think you
are you can feel on a deeper level you
feel people's feelings
nope so basically like you because
you're a nice guy but from but for like
most guys probably not not anyone you
probably mean the Hollywood that's not
the guys I'm [ __ ] cuz you know who
they are yeah yeah are you married I'm
going to be in three weeks knew it I got
married wives it's too late yeah yeah
god I'm good oh no way thank you for
that um we're almost we're running out
of time but I want to tell you talk
about everything you want to talk about
I want to tell you a funny thing that
happened that okay you tell me what you
think of this your periscope right yeah
so check this out so I'm in Philly
doing a show with another comic I'm not
gonna say his name on here even though
it's not hard to find after the show
we're in the hotel room hanging out
right and I turn on periscope we start
periscoping and this guy on my periscope
starts bragging about how last month he
bang 12 girls in one month or 15 some
crazy 15 girls in one month sure he's
lying he probably was lying but that's
what he says right and then he starts
talking about how he never changes his
bed sheets between girls because because
he's like he goes when I look at my bed
sheets and I see the different strands
of hair from the different girls I feel
proud like it turns me on
he says okay sounds like he has nothing
else going for him in his life he does
he's like a pretty good catch okay and
then he also says that his dicks been
burning but he thinks it's just because
he's been drinking too much okay I think
this may be your soul mate guys the one
for you and you know that's that and I
forget about it this is like two weeks
ago yeah fast forward to yesterday
this dude starts blowing up my phone
Kate you got to delete that periscope
the girl I'm dating saw it she thinks
I'm a total polish
[ __ ] now she heard me talking about all
these girls I [ __ ] and how my dick is
on fire was just typing it in right yeah
he's texting me this right he's texting
me that I got to delete the periscope
cuz all this happened his girl saw the
periscope and she's like freaking out
right I guess she was out to lunch with
her parents is the best and she's
talking about this guy she's been dating
she's like oh he's a comedian I'll look
him up and he's know she pays him up on
YouTube and somebody has been taking my
periscopes on YouTube so it's on YouTube
so I can't even delete it for him like
it's out there and she watches this
right away this whole time you tell me
this story I thought it was a guy in the
chat and now I'm realizing it was the
comedian it was the guy that was with me
in Philly some random person typing this
in no this is my friend no I'm getting
the story yeah this is my friend he said
she's like Kate we got to make another
pie when you say that he's mad at me I'm
like dude it's not my fault you say that
[ __ ] on social media how can you blame
me if somebody chai go 5000 people are
watching I can't help but if someone
took it and posted it that's not the
most disturbing part the bedsheets is
the most she be care being proud my
dicks on fire from drinking too much
orange juice and now I know who this is
the whole time I was like oh it's just
some random guy there's a thing I to get
to give him credit I just want to say in
case his girl is watching the minute I
turned off the periscope I was like that
was so funny and he's like oh I made a
lot of that up saying it was funny he
admitted right there in the moment that
wasn't all true but to his girl she
doesn't know and now it's on YouTube
it's on YouTube so she showed her
parents yeah and once she him yeah
saying this right so the lesson Wow
to know that anything I make fun of the
day in person yeah not here I know
people can figure it out but what's the
lesson what's the lesson the lesson is
don't say anything on any social
Media that you would not want your
significant other to find out about
don't tweet it
don't Facebook it don't Instagram it
unless they get you really well like
they got that you're like joking because
he's like dude you just lost me my girl
like he's so mad at me he texts her he
goes hey your birthday's this week I
want to take you out for a nice dinner
she goes why don't you hit up one of the
other 15 chicks you backed okay it's not
your fault you didn't he said those
things I know but I feel a little bad
recording it
he's on periscope I can when Josh and I
record dumb [ __ ] together
he's always not dumb [ __ ] when we're
recording you know whatever he's saying
dumb [ __ ] yeah he's like you know I I
come quick and I take my calm and I wipe
it on the bed stand there could be some
truth to it but I'm sure he's
exaggerating it which is that's what
this guy was doing yeah he was
exaggerating to be funny and you know
obviously oh my dad's calling it's Doug
should have answered on the air crap
sorry it's fine but anyway so yeah we
all say [ __ ] that you know I think is
exaggerated on stage I just gotten into
argument last night with a guy who I've
been talking to who wanted to come see
me perform and I was like no we haven't
been talking along enough I hate when
guys I'm dating want to see me perform
Yeah right no no don't because I'm
different now go to your work right hey
let me watch you edit this video no but
also like I don't know about your I say
[ __ ] on stage that like I don't mind a
stranger knowing but it's really
embarrassing and personal and I don't
really need you to hear it for the first
time on stage yes I'd rather hear it
eventually from me yeah it's such a
weird
I don't know how guys are cuz that's how
male comics get chicks they invite them
to their shows and they're just like
they they don't even know them they're
just like meeting them I know guys that
are just like yeah meet me at the call
Bevis set and then we'll hang out and
it's like this is I could never do that
could I ever be like oh this thing this
guy's hot
come see me but has the opposite effect
for us they see you on stage being like
I'm insane I send too many text messages
forty guys block my number this year and
they're like [ __ ] dating that bit
running out of here right right the guys
go on stage they like this chick got
bang last night all the girls like oh
maybe I'll be next like it's not the
same yeah or I just I feel like like
being a comic a female comic it's so I
hate to say female but whatever it's
like it's kind of like it's it's
powerful to go up there and like make a
roomful of people laugh and I think that
a lot of guys get intimidated by it
that's true and then although they like
I don't want to try it every guy I date
who's not a comic eventually he's like I
always wanted to try it it will kill me
so worse I'm bummed that we're almost
out of times I love talking to you we're
almost out of time do you have any like
horrific date story that you want to
share like your worst date fail or
recent date fail or worst sex anything
awful worst date date fail and worse sex
I would say was when I was uh this is
when I was like 23 this is literally the
third or third guy I slept with okay and
granted I was in a long-term
relationship so my number was low and we
weren't really drinking a lot I think
maybe we had like one beer or something
he wasn't drunk like he was completely
sober and we started hooking up and I I
was kind of like I I'm not I don't
really want like a cup with this guy but
I was like I'm already in his room so I
might as well I keep going you know like
you know yeah I know you feel like it's
almost like a pity [ __ ] at that point I
was young I was just like I'm here so
like I don't wanna like make him feel
about it like I was so stupid whatever
so we're it's more making out its
awkward we're gonna make it would start
having sex and it actually started I was
like oh this is actually pretty goddamn
maybe this might be a good decision and
he was on top of me and out of nowhere
his eyes roll to the back of his head
and turned white no in he fell on his
back off the bed on the floor and was
just unconscious and I was literally
like my first thought was like I should
just take my clothes and leave did you
think you killed him I didn't
know what happened because I know that
he wasn't on she wasn't like we weren't
drinking heavily like I don't we didn't
pass out from that you're just gonna
leave him by the way what the [ __ ] I'm
done
so then literally like three minutes
goes by and I'm like shaking him and he
wakes up and he's like what happened and
I was he breathing did you check no I
get scared I thought I could never be a
nurse I panic if there's blood and the
next thing I literally go I freeze and I
go huh for three minutes he was
unconscious I was shaking I'm shaking in
three minutes I'd say three minutes
that's like a long [ __ ] time and then
he woke up and he was like what he
literally said what happened and I was
like you passed out and I go are you
okay and he goes yeah that's been
happening recently I know you should you
should go to the doctor he's like yeah
and so then I'm like I think I'm just
gonna I'm gonna go did you ever hear
what was wrong with him did you ever
talk to him again I slept a little more
time did not you're like well that
didn't I have to at least come with this
guy once like he passed out before you
got me off I wish I was making this up
this is so real and he passed out again
no when you say date pill sex now I'm
telling you a real story passed out
again yes but it was so it was immediate
like we he literally like penetrated me
like twice and then passed out maybe
that's just the minute his dick goes in
he's like oh so good and he passes out
no you literally not guys out has this
ever happen you know your pussy's like
kryptonite for Superman he sticks his
dick in and just passed the [ __ ] out you
know what I've never talked about this
onstage uh why I don't know cuz I feel
like it's you have to I'm like it's too
real you have none
oh dude no I've been recently telling
stories on stage that are so mortifying
yes so embarrassing yeah so like really
if anyone saw it they would be like oh
my god I'm never dating that girl but it
is the funniest [ __ ] I've ever done you
just have to do the comedy I do comedy
is real but it's also like a part of me
is like well this guy lives in LA oh my
god who is she is he an actor is he a
calm actor he's an actor not successful
yeah he's like a writer actor do you
ever see him on TV you know I go there's
I wonder if he passes out when he's fake
[ __ ] I yeah I feel embarrassed why I
don't know in that scenario I thought
embarrassed but it was only a girl girl
would like a guy is [ __ ] you and he
passes out and you're like oh my god I'm
so embarrassed like it's your fault
somehow I know well that's
I apologize for two things that aren't
my fault so do I that's the daddy issues
you should come with me to see the Laugh
Factory therapist it's free if you're a
paid regular really oh my god looking at
Dana you are amazing that was making
date fails of all time I'm really
honored that you shared that here for
the first time just keeping it real I
really want to see who he is the minute
we get off yeah
guys please at Dana moon me on Twitter
Instagram periscope everywhere where
knapp chat at nap chat damn mooner oh do
you moon a lot on the snout her I don't
but moon me was taken so whatever you
are give it back to [ __ ] that
follow me @kq funny you guys are awesome
thanks for watching Dave day I'll see
you next time bye
dude that was that story